i had this client who was a mathematical
genius clinical client he taught me a
lot of things i didn't know i hadn't
learned as a statistician and one of the
things he talked to me about was the
pareto principle and so i went and
looked into that in some depth and so i
found for example that
it's so such a strange phenomenon it's
like
the square root of the number of people
operating in a specific discipline
produce half the output
that's the law and so there's a thousand
scientists working on a particular in a
sub-dis in a discipline 30 of them
publish half the papers
and you can look across it's the same
with basketball
hoops successfully managed hockey goals
scored soccer goals scored records
produced
books written books sold
records sold it's like everywhere this
this law this weird square root law
sometimes people sum that up as the 80
20 principle but it's way worse
yeah it's way worse than that
[Music]
hello everybody
i'm pleased today to have as my guest
professor glenn c lowry merton p stoltz
professor of economics at brown
university he holds a ba in mathematics
from northwestern and a phd in economics
from mit
he's published widely as an economic
theorist and researcher has lectured
throughout the world and is one of
america's leading analysts of racial
inequality he's been elected a
distinguished fellow of the american
economics association a member of the
american philosophical society and of
the u.s council on foreign relations
and is a fellow both of the economic
story econometrics society and the
american academy of arts and sciences
his youtube channel podcast the glenn
show often co-hosted with professor john
mcwhorter a linguist at columbia and a
recent guest on my youtube channel has
attracted an increasingly wide audience
i'm hoping to talk with professor lowry
about income distribution the pareto
principle his shifting political and
religious beliefs racial inequality etc
as well as his public presence on
youtube and via podcast thank you very
much for agreeing to speak with me today
i'm very much looking forward to this
conversation
good to be with you jordan i'm excited
great great so maybe we could start by
i'd like to get to know you a little bit
so how did you how did it come about
that you developed an academic career
well i was a working-class kid in
chicago and uh got to
a junior college i
i married quite young i dropped out of
college i found my way back to school at
a junior community college in chicago
and had a math teacher calculus
teacher who saw that i was really really
good at
differentiating and integrating
you know that i was that i was good at
these little mathematical puzzles he
said you're a smart kid you know
and it was 1970
it was uh
right you know at the height of uh the
vietnam protest and the
black power and all that northwestern
university wanted to recruit uh black
kids from chicago to come and study
there and i got recommended to their
attention and i ended up with a full
scholarship at northwestern where i
discovered
a serious
quantitative study in mathematics and
in
economics i took graduate courses while
an undergraduate at northwestern in both
math and econ and found myself at mit as
a graduate student in the early 1970s
took a phd there
um
did you know did you know that you had a
mathematical bent before you before you
were discovered so to speak at the
community college
i did i i was always good at math i i
was doing slide rule and logarithms and
stuff when i was in the sixth grade i
was uh
teaching my fellow eighth graders from a
algebra
you know problem set book
after class because it was just a hobby
that i
that i loved i was always good at math
but i had not had the opportunity to get
a really serious
education
uh until i got to northwestern and
that's when things
things took off all for me and mit you
know it was the best probably the best
economics department in the world in the
early 1970s
with students from all over who were
quite outstanding scholars and and i i
really found my niche
found my niche there
what i loved about it was formal
modeling applied to social questions
i liked math but it was arid and
abstract uh and it was the early 1970s
one wanted to be working on social
issues somehow and economics
was exactly
right for me because i found that you
could explore these questions with a
kind of rigor and a kind of disciplined
uh quantitative specification and you
know deductive logic and and applied
mathematics not deep not really really
deep mathematics but
uh you know
serious applied mathematics so
it was a natural fit for me
you know i liked
i took a clinical research degree and i
liked the science a lot the research
science but i really liked the fact that
my clinical practice enabled me to sort
of nail that down to earth all the time
so that was a lovely balance as well and
also sort of fed my interest in social
issues more at the individual level than
say the sociological level where did you
become convinced i mean you've got this
mathematical bent and and you were
trained at least at the bachelor's level
in mathematics per se
how convinced are you that the
application of mathematics to economic
models produces
results that are actually applicable to
the real world
oh well that's a big one applicable to
the real world um i mean i think what
you're doing
in uh formal economics this is a big
question early in the 20th century when
people like paul samuelson who was one
of my teachers was beginning to apply
you know the kind of mathematics that
you would see in uh theoretical physics
uh on dynamical systems or you know this
kind of
apply
and it was basically differential and
integral calculus and differential
equations and so on apply it to
classical problems and economics and a
lot of people thought well that's kind
of taking us away from the real world
and that's a kind of you know counting
angels on the head of a pen a kind of
you know abstract and and it's true that
one can get lost in the abstraction
uh but i think there are
deeper insights that can be generated
through the application of mathematics
that are closely connected to the real
world this is not empirical science this
is
this is theoretical but it's it's a you
kind of get to the bottom of it i mean i
could give an example
so the invisible hand theorem from adam
smith this is the late 18th century as
you know
is uh if you let people pursue profit
their own interest
uh at prices that are commonly uh
observed by everybody and they're in
competition with one another
then the outcome is going to be socially
efficient it's going to be pareto
efficient you were talking about pareto
just a minute ago it's going to be
pareto efficient now
that's kind of a deep insight in
what does it depend upon and i i uh
think that uh the
20th century
characterization
of what we mean by competition
what we mean by price has been common to
all people and profit-seeking and
self-interested on the part of consumers
it kind of crystallizes
exactly what you have to be assuming
about the behavior of individuals about
the institutional setting in order for
confidence in the
efficiency of
capitalist enterprise
to be justified
now it turns out that those conditions
and people like kenneth arrow the late
great kenneth arrow the economist
he was at stanford at the end of his
career
and others uh formalized this at mid
20th century turns out that those
assumptions are fairly
rigid those those assumptions are fairly
demanding there's there's plenty of
reason to believe that they may fail
and seeing
what the consequences of the failure of
those assumptions
are
is something that is facilitated by
formalizing
uh the problem and i mean i could give
other examples in political theory that
kenneth arrow again he has a famous uh
book called social choice and individual
values and then that book is a theorem
which he has to employ rigorous
mathematics to demonstrate but the
theorem says
that if you're looking for a mechanism
that for just about any kind of society
can aggregate individual preferences in
a
coherent and rational way
in order to formulate a social decision
rule
rooted in those individual preferences
unless your rule is dictatorial where
you designate one person to be the
decision maker for everybody else you
will be looking in vain it's an
impossibility theorem there are no
mechanisms majority rule doesn't satisfy
all the rationality requirements et
cetera et
that yeah it's cetera to me in some ways
and and enlightening and others let me
see if i can rephrase that and question
you a little bit about that so well when
i think about these sorts of problems
psychologically
um
in terms of how people
are able to make decisions to act
successfully in the world i see that
we're always contending in some sense
with with genuine uncertainty
and the the future is in some sense
actually unpredictable and so and none
of us are smart enough to figure out
exactly what's coming
and what we should do and so i tend to
view the free market as a giant
computational device that
does the best job that we can of
computing what's valuable at any given
point across the you know as vast a
number of individuals as we can possibly
manage and it isn't exactly that i think
that that works it's that i think i
can't see how anything else that we
could possibly do could work better
and so
they did and i'm not an economist and
i'm certainly not a mathematician there
might be all sorts of problems with that
sort of line of theorizing but i i see
it as distributed decision making that's
you know a consequence at least to some
degree of of the max maximum free choice
among the individuals concerned now i
know there's such thing as market
failures and et cetera but am i way up
way out
exactly right you're you're in friedrich
von hayek territory i mean you who you
know makes this argument in a very
classical way
uh because information is diffuse in
society and the idea that a central
bureau
of government uh fiat
could uh effectively manage all the
different trade-offs and coordination
problems and relative valuations and so
forth you know the computer's not big
enough to be able to do that and
moreover the information is not in one
place the information is in the hands of
many many different
decision makers
but
to the the the
uh
engine that makes that intuition of
yours work
is prices it's the fact that people are
seeing prices the prices carry all the
information they need
about
the relative
merits of one or another course of
action for themselves already
incorporating the kinds of calculations
that a central decision maker would find
it impossible to
to carry out
so i i think the way you summarize the
problem of the market being a mechanism
for calculating
very difficult allocation problems to
the
best effectiveness that's available to
us not perfect to be sure
i think that's correct and yes market
failures are when
that process goes wrong and it's usually
when
the prices don't reflect all the
different costs as for example in the
climate change
yeah well that that's a problem of
temporality to some degree right because
we can't compute
costs across all possible time frames
simultaneously and so when you're
talking about something that might have
a long-term cost it's like well how long
term of cost can we expect to adapt to
um you know if it's 150 years in the
future well we're all dead and it's very
difficult for us to take such things
into account and also our prediction our
margin of error expands terribly as we
move out into the future so okay so i
want to reverse that for a second this
will have some bearing on our later
discussion maybe so i
i kind of like the idea that the future
is unpredictable per se and that you
need distributed decision-making power
but i also spent a lot of time studying
cognitive ability and personality and so
what researchers have concluded
essentially is that if you study
cognitive ability which is something
like the ability to manipulate
abstractions at some rapid rate
you find that
it collapses statistically into a single
dimension whereas personality collapses
into five dimensions and that's c this
is g s g essentially yes and it's not
much different you could you can get a
pretty rough approximation of g by
taking any set of a hundred questions
that require abstraction to solve and
just averaging the score it'll be
correlated with g at like 0.7 or 0.8
which is a whopping correlation by
social science standards and so but
anyways you know the thing about let me
let me ask you a question
but i'm not a psychologist here's my
sort of statistically trained
understanding of that
which is that while we may not be able
to put our finger on any particular
neural pathway or any particular
uh biological process of going activity
going on in the brain nevertheless we
think that there is
an ability or an aptitude
that
manifests itself in the solution to
these abstract kinds of uh cognitive
problems we're going to call it g and
we're going to measure it by the
confluence
of a person's performance across a range
of different kinds of tests there's some
a factor analysis analytic kind of
distraction yes exactly
and you're saying that no matter what
the tests are kind of it all collapses
down to this this one
uh it doesn't matter what the tests are
you could take any set of 100 random
questions that require abstraction to
solve and you'll pull out something that
will be correlated with g if you average
the scores at about 0.7 or eight it's
it's remarkably unitary it's stunningly
unitary when someone like stephen j
gould is i recall him yeah he's wrong
okay
like and here's why you know he took an
issue with well he took issue with
factor analysis he said well that's not
real it's like well is the average real
yeah
it depends what you mean by real if if
it has a one factor solution it's
basically identical to the average not
exactly because all the questions aren't
related to that average equally but for
in the case of g for all intents and
purposes it's indistinguishable from the
average
and any random set of 100 questions will
do i mean i looked into this deeply
because we built personality models my
research team and and and they'd be
reasonably influential in the field of
personality so i understand that there
are phenomena that are associated with
human psychology they don't have a
uni-dimensional solution but gee man
it's a killer it's a black hole it sucks
all cognition into it and there's no
escaping it
so it's very now and so why brought that
up we will go back to that but why
brought that up is because it's kind of
weird to see that
there is this cognitive ability that
does allow for prediction of the future
that is associated reasonably strongly
statistically with long-term say life
economic success
in some ways that flies in the face of
the idea that a central authority can
can't model the future because we have a
central authority and i can speak about
it biologically for a second so
you move your body voluntarily with your
motor cortex
and the prefrontal cortex grew out of
that over an evolutionary time frame and
what the prefrontal cortex does is
represent action in abstraction
so that you can assess
well its mechanisms but also its likely
outcome before you implement it in
action and that seems to be it's not a
specifically human skill but we've
developed that far more than any other
creature
and so and it seems to work because
people with higher iqs tend to do better
say economically well they do better
across a large variety of of measures so
well that's sort of that
but it does fly in the face of that need
for distributed decision making i don't
see that i don't see how it is that
the ability to predict a person's uh i
don't know income or
whatever on the basis of their cognitive
ability
correlates or connects to the ability of
someone sitting in an office somewhere
to know
how much
you know uh farm material should be
shipped here and yeah maybe it's a
matter of complexity you know it maybe
that's what and diversity and and the
fact that it's it's not a
one-dimensional thing what we're after
when we when we ask what people want
they have preferences that are complex
and
they they and and i don't know who is
the person who wants a cool room or a
warm room in the wintertime uh they have
to reveal that to me by the actions that
they take something like that
yeah well so maybe it's maybe it's the
case that the central iq authorities so
to speak has a bounded universe that's
basically private in which it can make
reasonable predictions but once you
scale the problem up to a certain degree
of complexity you have to switch to more
distributed forms of cognition that
could easily be the case can i predict
whose marriage is going to survive based
on g
not that i know of you can predict whose
marriage is going to survive to some
degree based on trait neuroticism which
is the negative emotion dimension and so
higher levels of neuroticism
increase the probability of divorce and
that's part of the reason why most
divorces are initiated by women
that's going to get you in trouble
george yeah whatever i get in trouble
all the time but look i mean it's not a
sexist thing to say i mean there's
reasons that women are more sensitive to
negative emotion they're smaller
the the cost of sex is higher for them
and they have to be finely attuned to
the dangers posed to infants
and so it's an evolutionary there's
nothing wrong with the fact they have
higher levels of negative emotion it's
costly for them as individuals to some
degree because it's unpleasant and
physiologically demanding but it makes
perfect sense given that the world's
probably more dangerous for women
especially when they have infants
everything you said makes a lot of sense
to me
why is it so difficult to make
statements such as the ones that you've
made about the intrinsic or natural
differences between men and women based
on the very argument that you gave that
there's good evolutionary reasons why
well i i can play devil's advocate for
that so
as a psychologist
i do see a technical reason in some
sense for separating biological sex from
the concept of gender
and the reason for that is that i think
the best description of gender is
probably in personality
and men and women's personality are more
the same than they are different so the
curves overlap more than they differ the
biggest differences are a negative
emotion and compassion slash politeness
which is agreeableness and women are
higher in both reliably but
there are no shortage of women who have
a masculine temperament and no shortage
of men who have a feminine temperament
they're in a minority but the diversity
is there and so when you say something
like well on average females differ in
this way it's hard for people who don't
think statistically to sort of separate
that out from well that means everyone's
like that and well they're not there's
tremendous individual very five
dimensions of variability is a lot of
variability
and so
and there is more similarity between men
and women than there are differences the
biggest difference is b is in interest
actually and this is kind of interesting
for someone mathematically minded
because
there isn't much evidence that women and
men differ in mathematical ability at a
cognitive level maybe boys have a slight
edge in spatial reasoning and that might
yeah it might be linked to testosterone
and i think that's probably true but
it's it's slight but they have a
whopping different difference in
interest
and women are reliably more interested
in people and men are reliably more
interested in things compared to the
other sects i read charles murray's book
human diversity and uh the section of
that book on jitter
is etched very powerfully into my mind i
thought he made many strong arguments
there and around this point about
differences in interest and then of
course that causes people to invest in
different kinds of behavior and that
leads to
differentiation in their occupational
profiles and others well it's especially
true at the extremes
because you know even if the curves
overlap to a large degree in the middle
so that most men and women are roughly
the same
if the great mathematicians let's say
are one percent of the population which
is probably an overestimate then they're
almost all going to be men
despite that huge overlap and despite
the lack of cognitive difference i've
been a i've been a chess player a chess
player i'm just going to say all my life
and
the the dominance of men amongst the
world-class chess players is you know
it's
very very prominent i mean they
basically are very few women who play at
the top top rank of uh of chess players
yeah well you have to kind of be
obsessed with something like chess two
two to get that far right i mean it's a
real specialization at that level and so
if you're not compelled by your interest
you won't do it despite your ability
a relatively small difference in ability
at the right tail of the distribution
and spatial cognition for example might
lead to a very large difference in the
number of hours people allocate to
developing
their chess playing skills and then that
would account for the
gender difference and and top chess
performance
except yeah well and you also see this i
got in trouble for this a lot but but
it's true so that's life
in in in the scandinavian countries it's
proved very difficult to get women into
engineering and men into nursing and as
those countries have become more gender
equal in their legislation and their
social policies and likely their society
those differences have got bigger not
smaller so
it's
it's a stunning it's just underwater i
wonder what you would say to this
argument which is okay okay uh maybe you
guys have a point
but
the main political imperative is
equality for men and women that's a
political imperative and that means that
we have to sustain majorities in favor
of the kinds of laws and regulations we
need to achieve that
when you talk candidly and casually as
lauren summers did when he was president
of harvard university i'm sure you know
the incident that i'm oh yes
about women and why there aren't so many
at the top of mathematics and and uh the
stem disciplines when you talk casually
about that
you give aid and comfort to uh the
forces that uh want to resist equality
and and you kind of feed or fuel
something that needs to be uh needs to
be opposed not need not to be encouraged
so you ought to censor yourselves a
little bit have some uh
modesty in the way in which you talk
about these issues because the stakes
are very high something like that do you
find that yeah well i'd agree with oh
yeah but you know the way i deal with
that as i don't speak casually about
such things like i i i did my research
on these topics this is years of
research and i was dead serious about
partly because we built practical tools
to assess personality and cognitive
ability as well as i studied it as a
researcher and you know as an interested
as an interested clinician and so none
of this is casual and
no i don't think that censoring myself
is the right idea because i think to
really say if we wanted to eliminate
those gender differences in occupation
the
intensity of government intervention
that would be required would tilt things
towards something that's too much too
totalitarian you'd have to interfere
with people so much to accomplish that
it's a one standard deviation at least
difference in interest between men and
women and people and things and then if
you do foster social equality like the
scandinavians have clear they've clearly
done that by any reasonable measure
and the fact that those differences get
bigger it's like you just can't walk
away from that it's not what anyone
expected on the left or the right no one
expected that
and what seems to happen is if you give
men and women every opportunity in some
ways they get much more different
and so you know hey we didn't expect
that but that's science isn't it all
very very frequently things that you
don't expect happen
so yeah
okay well you you persuade me on that
one
yeah well
it's not easy to see how you could set
up government policies that would
violate people's intrinsic interest and
one of the things you do learn as a
personality researcher is that those
interests
are deep they're biologically rooted in
many ways so if you're an open person so
that's create that's creativity
dimension
that's deep deeply rooted inside of you
it's a fundamental element of who you
are it can't be easily trifled with or
safely trifled with
by
well let's say by political interests
and i really saw that as a clinician
because i'd have people who were
creative as clients and if they weren't
doing creative work they could hardly
stand to be alive
well this is a theme that might apply
across a number of areas the theme being
a pursuit of a faux egalitarianism an
equality in a place where
the natural order of things would not
have equality be expected but the
ideology of egalitarianism
uh
is set against the
uh objective reality of the of the
difference that we're talking about and
people want to make equal in any case we
want to have we want to force we want to
force engineering departments to recruit
women so that they have a 50 50 balance
or whatever it might be we want to
subsidize or tax or discourage and
encourage people's behavior so as to
bring about this equal outcome well you
know as a heuristic you know as a
heuristic you might say that if you look
at outcome
and you see gender differences or ethnic
differences or racial differences
sometimes you can reliably infer
barriers and prejudice and so as a
heuristic it's not bad right because
that points to a place where there might
be a problem but then we do have some
areas where we have high resolution
knowledge like let's say with regard to
interest in people versus things and so
then we can say well wait a sec that
difference doesn't look like it's a
consequence of arbitrary prejudice
so but i think i don't like well look
one of the things i was interested in
talking to you about you've written a
fair bit about
dif racial differences in incarceration
in the united states yeah and you've
made a case and i don't want to put
words in your mouth but i'm trying to
sum up what i understand
that the fact of those differential
incarceration rates not only has a
variety of negative medium and long-term
consequences for everyone
but that
it does point to a kind of system
systemic problem that's fundamentally
discriminatory
and to some degree that's use of that
heuristic i would say and and in a
perhaps in in an entirely appropriate
way it's complicated but
am i have i got your argument reasonably
i wouldn't have said or i wouldn't say
today in any case fundamentally
discriminatory without unpacking that
yeah i i would say that the disparity uh
here you have the state that deprives
people of liberty it's a very massive
footprint incarceration in the united
states and there's a huge racial
disparity in it there's also a racial
disparity in criminal offending
i would make the case that even if you
could account for every single person
incarcerated
uh by reference to
well they
broke the law they did the crime they're
doing the time and even if you could
count
roughly
that the african-american
over-representation in prison is
commensurate with their
over-representation amongst criminal
offenders
still
the fact that this is the state
coming down
with a hammer on people and confining
them and depriving them of their liberty
at the scale that it's engaged in given
the history of our society where
racial difference is such a fraught and
sensitive matter given the existence of
stereotypes in the minds of people
that are buttressed by the
over-representation of african-americans
in prison given the political alienation
in the communities from which the
prisoners are coming and all that can be
loaded onto that in terms of uh of a
lack of a pers
of the granting of legitimacy to the
forces of order in the society
given the history which is a history
that is marred by
racial etc etc that it would be a bad
thing
for that disparity to persist and it's
it's an outcome that government ought to
work to counteract
not because they think it's mainly a
consequence of discrimination
at least ongoing current contemporary
discrimination but because the ultimate
stability of our of our social order
depends upon not allowing that to fester
uh unattended right i've said i've said
a million cases each one rightly decided
can still add up to a great and historic
wrong and that's the sense in which i
lamented uh this is years ago i don't
write so much about it anymore but in
any case i lamented the racial disparity
in incarceration i thought it was bad
for our society even if it
reflected mainly
disparity in criminal offending because
of course criminal offending doesn't
fall from the sky either it's a
consequence of social structure and
social organization to some degree as
well as the personality and moral uh
characteristics of different uh
individuals in society
but yeah i was concerned about mass
incarceration primarily because i
thought it made solving the american
dilemma
all that much more difficult uh to to
accomplish
yeah well you also wrote to some degree
about its its effect on disrupting
families you know on an ongoing and
continuing basis and you know i've i've
spent a fair bit of time trying to
wrestle with the potential role that
fathers play in families in relationship
let's say to the disciplinary structures
that are applied both to young men and
young women and
and it certainly seems to me that in
these differential incarceration rates
are tremendously destabilizing for the
fundamental family structure
among well
what and
when you've looked at that let me ask
you two questions
do
what do you think the data show about
the severity of sentencing for blacks
versus whites in the u.s for crimes of
the same magnitude
and i know that's not bottom level data
but how do you see that because you
talked about criminal offending
yeah
now you can find studies where they are
are going to see some
modestly more severe
punishment conditional on the crime
for black offenders but my general sense
of the matter and i
rest here on my service on a committee
of the national academy of sciences uh
that reported maybe seven or eight years
ago
uh causes and consequences of high rates
of incarceration in the united states my
understanding of that literature from
people like
uh he's up in years now but he's been
very influential alfred bloomstein he's
a statistical criminologist at carnegie
mellon university he's kind of the
godfather of these studies there are
many other studies my understanding is
that
you can account cannot account for more
than
15-20 percent of the racial disparity in
people in prison by reference to
differences in
the
uh length of sentence or the likelihood
of being convicted and sentenced
conditional on offense okay so they're
great nothing great
no it's not nothing it's not nothing but
it's the great bulk of the disparity is
uh differences in offending
uh uh what about the probability of
being arrested for an offense
okay another 15 or 20 percent
these things are going to be hard to
estimate aren't they probably oh yeah
you're not observing the non-arrested
offenders
uh you're observing you're observing
user surveys of people who have been
offended against and in those surveys
there'll be reports about the perceived
race of the person who's offending so
maybe you could attempt to back into
some estimate of the conditional
likelihood of being uh
apprehended
given uh race and there might be some
racial difference there 15 sounds like
that could be a lot yeah well it could
go the other way too because it isn't
obvious to me whether the black
community in the u.s is over policed or
under policed i think you could make a
theoretical argument for either what
what do you think in reporting the
reporting of offenses is also going to
differ by social location uh domestic
violence for example may or may not be
reported with the same degree of
uh fidelity uh across social class and
racial uh identity i actually don't know
this to be the case but it's certainly
plausible that
so it's it's it's pretty slippery
um but i'd say the the majority of the
racial disparity is a reflection of
disparity and offending
the difference in sentencing conditional
on the fence may differ by race
disfavoring blacks now uh in the drug
area that's a specific thing where it's
observed that drug use patterns don't
differ nearly as much by race as
drug
incarceration patterns do
but i explain that in my mind by
reference to the fact that
open-air drug markets are going to
attract on the selling side
uh people from the you know who don't
have many positive alternative
opportunities to use their time it's a
low-paying and very dangerous trade it's
no surprise that i have to go to the
wrong side of the tracks in order to
engage in a you know prohibited commerce
then the people who are going to be
engaged in that commerce will to be
disproportionately from disadvantaged
communities
um so on
do you i talked to some psychologists
for a fair bit of time it was margo
wilson and
and uh
unfortunately i can't remember the name
of her
her uh
martin daley margot wilson and martin
daley they've done interesting work
looking at the relationship between
economic inequality and crime and what
they've showed state by state and
country by country is that and county by
county in the u.s is that the higher the
rates of
inequality economic inequality in a
given geographical locale
the higher the rates of
aggression and criminality and what they
and they studied chicago the inner city
of chicago specifically in relationship
to this research and their hypothesis
was that
young men it's very important for the
sexual success of young men to be on an
upward path
in relationship to status and in places
with high inequality
that's an indication that their upward
mobility is truncated in various ways
and as a consequence they're highly
likely to turn to
violence and criminality as an
alternative means of obtaining status
and that's part of what's driving the
sorts of things that you're describing
and
they're they're look they show very high
correlations between income inequality
county by county and rates of of male
aggression especially among young men
and like the correlations are 0.6 0.7
unbelievably high for social science
so
well that's interesting that's news to
me but that that's a
seeking status and when you can't do it
by uh
high income then you do it by uh
you do it by hooker by crook because
it's so fundamentally important and
especially for young men because
for there's here's another gender
difference they're competing for the
services of young women is that is that
yeah
status as a marker for competence way
more than young men do so young women
are much choosier as sexual partners for
obvious reasons this cost to sex is a
lot higher for them and what they are
looking for is something like
competence in climbing social ladders
and then they use social status as a
marker for that
and so that question
if there are these deep psychological
social psychological dynamics at work
how much influence can
culture
you know
play in affecting people's behavior
can we change the script or are we
locked in
are we locked in by these kind of very
deep imperatives
of the sort that you would just i would
say that we're constrained but within
that constraint there's there's no
shortage of room for choice you know
it's sort of like chess there's rules
but man there's a lot of ways to to to
affect the chess game and these more
biological factors are more like they're
more like game rules and it doesn't in
some real sense doesn't decrease
the range of choice it shapes the game
and then socially well
status is going to be more important as
a marker for male desirability than for
female desirability we're not going to
change that but what we can do is
restructure social systems so that
non-violent means of obtaining status
are available as much as possible to
everyone and that's sort of the equality
of opportunity argument except maybe
from a biological perspective
and it's also the inequality issue is
also extremely interesting as far as i'm
concerned because what their work
suggests and it's pretty damn solid i i
believe that
um
inequal economic inequality as such
poses a destabilizing threat to
societies as such and the reason for
that is that that it promotes
young male violence particularly and so
whether you're on the left or the right
it's like inequality is a problem if it
gets too extreme things get violent
so
adolescent for conservatives as well as
as well as people on the left
so
okay but inequality is inevitable is it
not and well that's another thing i
wanted to talk to you about well let's
talk about that and because
i had this client who was a mathematical
genius clinical client he taught me a
lot of things i didn't know i hadn't
learned as a statistician and one of the
things he talked to me about was the
pareto principle and so i went and
looked into that in some depth and so i
found for example that
it's so such a strange phenomenon it's
like
the square root of the number of people
operating in a specific discipline
produce half the output
that's the law and so there's a thousand
scientists working on a particular in a
sub-dis in a discipline 30 of them
publish half the papers and you can look
across it's the same with basketball
hoops successfully managed hockey goals
scored soccer goals scored records
produced
books written books sold
records sold it's like everywhere this
this law this weird square root law
sometimes people sum that up as the 80
20 principle but yeah it's way worse way
i heard it yeah it's way worse than that
it's way worse than 80 20. yeah well
it's it implies for example if you have
an organization with ten thousand people
a hundred of them doing half the work
you know if you have ten it's three and
that's not so bad but at ten thousand
it's a hundred and you think no way it's
like well if you meet some of those
people who might be in that hundred
you you might think differently
so
and this looks like this some
fundamental rule and so
you're interested in income distribution
and so
what do you make of this sort of thing
well it reminds me of a classic paper by
the late economist sherwin rosen
university of chicago called the
economics of superstars
and he starts it out by observing 80 20
like observations by you know
let's look at the earnings of tennis
players and look at the rank
so how much total
prize money is won by tennis players and
what proportion of it goes to people
based on the rank and he gets something
like an 80 you know the top you know 20
or 25 tennis players have taken in you
know the vast majority of the winnings
and it you know record sales by um
musicians in various genres of musical
production and whatnot similarly the top
ones are getting most so he says how can
we account for this and
uh
this i think should be a part of
anybody's effort to explain uh the
pareto principle as you've uh defined it
or the 80 20 rule
he says
look
to
produce um
something that people want to see you
need talent but you also need other
resources and so it's the combination
of the
productivity of the talent which is
scarce and distributed in the population
and
the effectiveness of their ability to
command other resources which taken
together
determine
what they will be able to produce
all right so you need a combination so
imagine one distribution would be talent
and so you need to be in say the top ten
percent but that's not enough you also
need i don't know you need to be in the
top ten percent of education say to be a
successful research to scientist and the
juxtaposition of those two curves
produces a real fractional percentage
and those people are hyper qualified for
that particular enterprise it's
something like that
he adds another element which is let's
take opera singers he uses this example
so
in the old days before you had high
quality
sound reproduction such that you could
sit in your living room and listen to a
recording of an opera singer
through your speakers that produced an
effect that was almost as good as being
in the opera house before that before
that
you had to actually go to the opera
house to hear opera now the opera house
can only accommodate a couple of
thousand people max so
the very very very best opera singers
could still only command an audience of
a couple hundred hundred thousand people
in any given performance which leaves
plenty of room for the second third
fifth and thirtieth best to be able to
travel to the small towns and still make
a living
but once it becomes possible for the
best to record their uh performance and
to distribute it in that way the person
sitting in the small town has a choice
do i go to hear a 20th rate opera singer
in the local hall or do i put a
recording of the best one on my device
now
often they would choose to go with the
recording rather than to go to the 20th
best and that means that the top opera
singers are now going to command an even
greater
share of the market and the insight
there is that technological change which
permits the most talented to lever their
talent to a larger audience is the key
to understanding why they get so much of
the of the take
completely right right well you can so
it's like
the smaller the game
the less the gain at the top but we
expand the games continually with
technology and recording is an excellent
example of that and so i guess what we
hope is that we produce enough new games
so that everybody can win at something
but we're still we're still funneling a
tremendous number of resources to people
at the top of whatever the game is
especially as these games become big
so
yeah and you see that you see that
particular well it's really obvious with
money and people complain continually
about the top one percent but the
problem is is that there's a book called
big science little science that was
written in about 1962 and the author
escapes me at the moment but he did
exactly the same sort of analysis for
the scientific literature it's exactly
the same story
so hyper dominance of a tiny minority of
people and so there's a natural it's
something like positive feedback loops
too isn't it because and i've noticed
this as i've become more famous i
suppose is that
you get known and some more people know
you and so more people are likely to
attend you and then more people are
willing to talk to you because you have
an audience and so that drives the
expansion of the audience and your
connection network grows at the same
time and you have more resources and so
it just it's a pause it's a bunch of
positive feedback loops moving upward
i think the word network is very
important there and i i think what with
social media and whatnot
and and uh the
magnifying the ability of individuals to
uh have influence and uh to have
influence on people who have influence
the the density of that network is a is
a tremendous asset for uh
uh you know
yeah so it makes its competitive
position well it makes the problem of
inequality a real tough one from the
political perspective right because we
could and conceptual for that matter
because we could perhaps agree that
regardless of whether you're on the left
or the right you might view inequality
on the right as a threat to social
stability so i know there's this uh
native canadian tribe on the west coast
haida the quack quackwacks did the same
thing
you know in their societies they'd have
big chiefs and
the big chiefs would just accrue
everything
and then now and then they'd have a
potlatch and give it all away and then
their status was dependent on their
ability to give a lot away
and that stabilized their society now
those were made illegal by the canadian
government i think about 70 years ago or
so but you know they were thought of
just some pagan
an unnecessary pagan ritual i suppose
but
i do believe that that was one of their
so-called evolved solutions to the
problem of the terrible problem of
inequality the fact that you know goods
tend to accrue in the hands of a few and
and the lefties that i see the left
political thinkers economic thinkers as
well
especially the ones on the extreme left
they tend to associate that with
capitalism but that's a fundamental
underestimate of the magnitude of the
problem in my thinking and
that's a real problem if you're
concerned about you know comparatively
poor or actually poor people it's way
bigger problem i wonder if we could
apply the same kind of thinking that we
use to explain why uh
athlete or a musician or even an
entrepreneur might end up
at the very right end of the
distribution
garnering for themselves a great bulk of
the of the reward
to apply that to the huge financial
fortunes that
um are uh accumulated either through you
know savvy in the marketplace you know
i'm a hedge fund guy i know what to buy
and when and when to sell
or to uh the the fortunes of land
holding you know family uh fortunes and
things of this kind
um i i i wonder whether those simple uh
insights uh
extend to the
institutionalized
wealth generating process well i think i
think they do to some degree i mean i
studied entrepreneurial success as a
researcher for quite a long time too
because
one of the personality factors that
predict entrepreneurial ability is this
trait openness which is essentially
creativity and
what defines creative thinkers in part
is so here's a simple creativity test
and it actually is reasonably predictive
of creative capacity both in terms of
originality of thought and creative
productions as assessed by experts how
many uses can you think of for a brick
in three minutes gonna write them down
or even how many four-letter words can
you think of in a minute that start with
c
that'll be correlated at about point
three or four with your creativity
depending on how it's measured very
simple test and what seems to happen is
that creative people when they think of
one idea
the probability that that will
trigger an associated idea is higher
especially a distally associated idea so
that likely means that creative people
have more erroneous ideas as well
and then they have to you know what
would you say edit them and select but
one of the things that makes creative
entrepreneurs successful
is that they produce a large variety of
creative products and then they throw
them out in the marketplace and most of
them fail but you just need one to hit
that pareto point and then you're
successful so you throw you know it's
you throw some what do you do throw a
mess at the wall and see what sticks
essentially and most entrepreneurs
before they're successful have had a
very large number of failures because
even if you're intelligent and creative
the probability that you'll build a
product that's actually timed for the
market is extremely low
so well what do you do well you create
more and that's what happens that's what
creative people are essentially
biologically predisposed to do
so i think that yeah i think that
principle
that underlying principle of positive
feedback loops and you know the
combination of scarcity of of of ability
and resources i think it accounts for
all those
inequalities so you know question is
what do we do about that well you were
saying something i thought interesting a
moment ago about how even a right winger
ought to be able to see that inequality
unrestrained could be dangerous to the
stable social order because the losers
losers are going to end up having to say
one way or the other at the end of the
day and you better watch out uh because
if they don't have a stake in the system
and they're feeling aggrieved and
uh without status and dignity uh they
may act out in ways that are hard oh
they will especially if they're young
men absolutely they will they absolutely
they will and that is definitely
dangerous and so you know partly we've
tried to solve that so to speak we in
the west by trying to ensure something
like equality of opportunity across a
wide range of games that's not a bad
sort of meta solution right it's like
well we can't predict we know that
there's going to be wild disparities in
outcome and we can't really do anything
about that but maybe we can give people
something approximating an equal shot at
winning some game
and that would be better for everyone
too because then we can harness their
creative resources and it isn't obvious
to me that there is a better so
technically even i can't see like i
don't understand
i don't know what a better solution
could be now what does that mean in a
world where the people who have
engineering degrees or gotta got to law
school or
uh got a good uh uh you know education
and and are connected are making six
figures
and living comfortably and and someone
who dropped out of high school is
working for thirty thousand dollars a
year and just barely getting by what is
that ladder guys venue where uh he or
she can feel like they're winning the
game
well i think it depends to some degree
on each individual you know i mean you
can find status and meaning in your
family
you have your pursuits outside of your
work i'm not saying that money isn't a
good singular marker of relative status
it's probably the best singular marker
there is but it's not the only one right
there are diverse there are diverse
places where you can attain status
and so and you know you know you can be
poor and dignified you've certainly met
people like that you there you can be
poor and admired within your family you
can be poor enough decent or outstanding
character for that matter and
so
and that's how
that's not exactly a domain that's
regulated socially like the economic
domain but it's not nothing
and so and by the same token you know
you can sacrifice a lot of those things
to economic pursuit and then you'll have
lots of money but man your life sucks
and in 50 different ways
so
i don't know if that's a sufficient
solution but it's not nothing
but this is not counseling laissez-faire
if i understand it it's not saying the
government should just withdraw and let
the chips fall within may
it could be apollo advocating for a
policy of some kind of you know
everybody needs work that's meaningful
uh you know everybody needs a kind of
sense of security you know that they're
not gonna get sick and not be able to
pay the bill they're not gonna get old
and not know where the next meal is
coming from uh let's guarantee let's try
to guarantee to the extent that we can
we know it's the world's not just uh
perfect and we may not be able to solve
all these problems let's let's try to
make sure that there's decent housing
for someone that's not so they don't
have to sleep on their bridge et cetera
et cetera and then let then we can let
the chips fall with it yeah well it
seems to me that societies like
well the u.s to some degree but more
specifically i would say the
scandinavian countries and probably
canada would more or less fall into that
what ballpark and we fall into a
ballpark it's pretty bad metaphor but
you know that's kind of what what those
democratic socialist countries have
tried to
establish now it seems to be easier to
do that in a smaller country that's more
homogeneous in its ethnic and racial
grouping and maybe also technically it's
easier with a smaller population you the
u.s is so damn big
it gets very complicated to try to do
the same thing you know that those
smaller qualities have managed
and and then of course there's
because you might think of something
like a guaranteed a guaranteed income
let me ask you something about that yeah
maybe it'll bolster the idea
so when i was a clinician i worked with
a lot of people who were
uh impaired in their cognitive ability
so they probably had iqs around 80 or
lower
and so and if if if you're if you have
cognitive ability at that range it would
be hard for you to master something like
folding a letter to get it into an
envelope and that's way harder than you
think because you have to
fold it exactly in thirds you can't be
out by more than about an eighth of an
inch
and so i i had one client i probably
trained him for 30 hours to do that well
enough so that the letters would go
through an automated
machine
so that he could keep his volunteer job
but anyways
the us military has been doing cognitive
testing since world war one about
and they determined
i don't remember when and this is part
of american legislation that you cannot
be inducted into the armed forces if you
have an iq i think less than 80.
and the reason they determined that is
because they couldn't find any military
job of any sort that
someone who is that cognitively impaired
could manage proficiently and you think
that's that's a killer issue because
it's not like the military
isn't
highly desirous of pulling people in
especially among from say the working
class so they were motivated to find the
opposite and that's like 10 percent of
the population and so here we have a
problem and he and no one will face this
as far as i can tell liberals are
conservatives
10 percent of the population can't
really function in the complex cognitive
environment and that's what we're
producing for everyone to live in and we
don't no we can't have a conversation
about that because you know the liberal
types think well everyone can be trained
to do anything which is complete bloody
rubbish and the conservatives think well
you know if you just buckle down and
work
away you go and there's some truth in
that because conscientiousness does
predict long-term economic success but
that doesn't deal with this other issue
at all it's ten percent of the
population
of the population they're so impaired in
terms of their cognitive functioning
that there's no useful word for them in
the in the military well you can take
that are we talking about in the
military well the reason i i think the
military example is so compelling is for
two reasons is that you know america in
particular has used the military as a
means of social mobility right because
it moves people from the working class
upward and that's been a conscious
policy decision in part so there's that
but the other part is you know often the
military is pretty damn hungry for
people
and so if if they've decided that well
this doesn't work
it's hard to see
well i buy it and that's partly well
because i know how much intellectual
variability there is between people it's
stunning and and terrifying at the same
time it's not a positive thing it's it's
it's
not i don't know existing this idea that
we can't find anything for them to do i
mean uh
but it and and to what extent does
you remember the bell curve
yeah who could okay yeah i was at
harvard when that came out and hernstein
was still a professor there so and i
only want to talk about a little bit i
read the bell curve a couple of times
and
one of the things hernstein and murray
said in that book that really stuck in
my mind is that
academic types like you and me
we virtually never encounter anyone in
the lower 50th percentile of the
cognitive distribution you know when we
think in undergraduates dim they have an
iq of 110
and that's like 80th percentile
and so you get blinded as you move up
the especially the academic ladder you
get blinded to the bottom
15 of the cognitive distribution because
you just never they're those people are
not in your purview they're not in your
circle
okay i'll take that point i can't use my
personal experience but
what what i'm chafing at is that okay
i'm i'm uh wearing glasses because i
don't see very well without them and i'm
undoubtedly in the distribution of
visual acuity
in the bottom i don't know 10 15
but when i put on pair of glasses
i am able to function
and what i'm what i'm missing here is a
consideration of whether or not we can't
adapt our institutions
of uh
you know
productivity or human service or
education or whatever
so as to meet this minimum requirement
which is taking everybody
for almost everybody giving them
something to do giving you something to
do yeah well that needs to be done and
look i i only add a couple of things to
this so in the iq literature because you
might think well that's biology and it's
immutable okay no not exactly there's
this flynn effect has shown that over
the last hundred years iq on average has
been rising and a huge part of that is
probably better nutrition
in the lower quartile of the population
so that made a huge difference people
got smarter because they weren't
starving essentially they weren't
malnourished
and then
there is evidence too that
so it's not like this is exactly
unremediable but the distribution
doesn't seem to change much
you know what i mean it doesn't pack
tighter into the middle you still have
the problem that p some people are
extremely smart and fast and some people
aren't and so
well it's a hard pro it's a very very
hard problem to solve i'm not saying
that we shouldn't solve it and that we
shouldn't pay some attention to the
people who are struggling at the bottom
we absolutely should but it isn't
obvious exactly it isn't obvious how to
do it
so i'll get this guy worked with i mean
like i said he probably had an iq maybe
something around 80 i would have
estimated you know and i tried to find
him a job
now it was really hard
he had a volunteer job in a bike shop
for a while and and it was a bike book
shop a real you know a small enterprise
and he could sort of put books in the
shelf although he couldn't sequence them
very well and then that place couldn't
pay him
and so then i got him a volunteer job at
a charity and he couldn't do it well
enough they were going to fire him and i
went and talked to the director of the
charity i said you can't fire this guy
because he's going to kill him it's like
think about this
he's 40.
he's got a volunteer job at a charity
and there he's going to get fired it's
like how the hell do you recover from
that
now he quit two months later anyways and
then he got a job
with someone who trained dogs and that
worked out just fine but you get my
point it's like
it was virtually impossible to find him
a niche and i i tried for with his
mother who was
extraordinarily devoted to him in a very
positive way we tried for three years
really to to slot him in somewhere
and
it was it was virtually impossible
so are you thinking that our
homeless shelters and the the prisons of
the country and
so on are basically populated by people
such as this who are uh unable to get
their foot on the bottom rung
no i wouldn't
the evidence for a relationship between
iq and criminality that's not very
strong
so i wouldn't say that in relationship
to incarceration
i i would say it's more likely
in homelessness and that sort of thing
that's more likely where people you know
they fall out of the economy because
there isn't anything they can find that
will pay them
a wage that will enable them to live
so
but but the iq relationship with
criminality isn't very high i'm keenly
aware of how politically incorrect this
whole conversation you and i are having
i i just read a piece in the atlantic i
think it was about a woman i believe
she's a cognitive psychologist i don't
recall her name just now she was at the
russell sage foundation
and met with a fierce uh pushback
uh when she had just attempted to assert
that
uh variation in human intelligence was
associated with variation in human
populations with other kinds of oh
genetics it was genetics i'm sorry
genetic variation wasn't just
intelligence it wasn't just intelligence
but she was saying look people are
different
the
ability for us to understand the genome
much better now allows us to document
that to some degree there's distribution
in the population and it's associated
with the distribution of outcomes that
we're concerned about and there was a
firestorm approach oh yeah well it's no
wonder man you can't dive into the iq
literature without coming away like
shell shocked in 15 different dimensions
i mean because certainly a huge part of
g
proficiency is biologically
what would you say
by
it has a biological foundation i mean i
was reading about john von neumann the
other day you know and people who knew
him and einstein thought he was way
smarter than einstein and that's not
nothing
he could multiply eight-digit numbers in
his head when he was 10.
two eight-digit numbers
oh that's that's a prodigy yeah yeah
well he exactly you know he might have
had the most he might have had the most
magnificent mathematical mind ever
and like
that's way out on the distribution right
i mean he had a huge impact in economic
theory by the way and that was just a
hobby it was something he was doing out
of his back pocket it wasn't even what
they really cared about yeah exactly
exactly and you meet people like that
now and then but not very often you know
and and they're so damn smart you just
can't bloody well believe it and
and and that's the case you know and
then with regards to socialization you
know well it's pretty easy to make
someone dumber but it's not that easy to
make them smarter and for obvious
reasons you know it's a lot easier to
wreck something than it is to improve it
and so that is the fact this fact of
that pre-determination in some sense
really is a sorrowful
what would you call it fat it's a
sorrowful fact
yeah a tragic a tragic reality might be
one way of putting it that uh it's
simply if given in our
in our nature that we have to reckon
with
and the temptation to
want to not see it and not accept it
uh is can be very powerful well and i
can understand exactly why because well
first of all
generally the people who discuss such
things don't have a lot of hands-on
experience with people in the bottom
success tile let's say the bottom
one-sixth so they just don't know
how much difference there is in the
range and i've administered iq tests to
all sorts of people and you can't
believe what people don't know and can't
compute it's it's it's beyond
comprehension in some ways at the bottom
but then also at the top i had a
graduate student at harvard
she didn't know anything about
statistics when i first met her and four
months later she was teaching statistics
at a graduate level
she was unbelievable and she was almost
that gifted
uh verbally as well now she had some
social problems that might have been
associated with her
remarkable cognitive ability but you
know it was unreal she made more
progress in four months in the
statistical realm than i did in 15 years
okay so there are differences amongst us
so both ends of the of the spectrum and
uh we need to learn how to live with
them
yeah well part of it is to admit it and
and to see if we can do that politically
without getting you know bogged down in
accusations and the weeds and that's a
real difficult thing to do
and it's not like i know exactly how to
do it but
but i'm not going to ignore
what i learned and and i'm not going to
ignore the social consequences of it
it's like
life's a lot harder for people in the
bottom ten percent of the cognitive
distribution there's no the southern the
southern poverty law center has
classified charles murray as a white
supremacist
this is an organization that is a
watchdog for uh
a white supremacist yep
i mean not a lot of people are going to
stick their head up out of the foxhole
if that's what's waiting for him
yeah that's for sure that's for sure
well you know i would also say one other
thing that you know
would probably make me unpopular among
psychologists too mostly but there isn't
a single phenomenon documented in the
social sciences that we know more about
than
the
psychometrics of cognitive ability
if you throw that out you throw
everything else out because
not the people who established
psychometrics of intelligence also
established all the statistical
techniques that all social scientists
use to assess and evaluate their data
you just don't get to throw it out and
that's also unfortunate because it's a
dismal literature in many ways because
the
the differential between people is so
unbelievably extreme and it matters well
here's where we are in in economics
there are people who are arguing in
popular press and magazines and so forth
that you shouldn't put a cognitive
ability measure on the right-hand side
of your regression regression equation
when you're trying to explain wage
variation in the population
they think that that is a is a morally
objectionable thing to do
differences amongst people in earnings
are to be understood in any way that you
can other than well that's totally true
it's completely idiotic it's completely
idiotic because
part of look
part of what puts you up in that
upper
end of the distribution is something
like speed right so imagine there's some
desirable place to get economically
maybe you're designing computer chips
that's a good example
well if you're faster you're going to
get there sooner and then you're going
to reap the economic rewards and that
speed is assessed with g it's it's a
function of g c got computational speed
and so
and then you know you also might say
well these damn tests are culture loaded
and that's a reasonable potential
objection but
i've never seen a culture fair test that
has the same validity no one's ever been
able to produce them and basically
people gave up in the 1960s the best
they've ever come up with is the ravens
progressive matrices and it's a pretty
good so imagine
it took a bunch of single tests of of
intelligence
and then you've you got the manifold
which is the average across all tests
you could pick the test that correlated
best with that manifold
and that's the raven's progressive
matrices
and so and it produces differences
so
i don't know what to do with that
you know you can't throw your hands up
and say well it's insolvable
but you can't not take it into account
because then you underestimate the
burden that people at the bottom end of
the distribution carry when they're
trying to struggle uphill you know and
you say well all you have to do is work
hard because that's the conservative
attitude and conscientiousness is an
indic it's personality trait it's an
indicator of work ethic and it's
correlated with economic outcome at
about 0.25 something like that
but cognitive ability is correlated at
about 0.5
so
yeah work hard work really matters but
doesn't matter as much as intelligence
so
yeah you don't have to convince me i'm
i'm again just struck by the political
climate uh of the time and the um the
fierce resistance to this kind of
causal of
attribution to intrinsic
uh characteristics of individuals
especially those under genetic control
and when you put it in
a racial disparity context then all bets
are off i mean it just becomes
impossible
yeah well it or or it compels you to
look for a a deeper reason
you know let me give you an example a
research example i worked with richard
tremblay and
he is one of the worst leading experts
on the development of aggressive
behavior and he was trying to ameliorate
it among children
and used interventions that got
into younger and younger kids and
finally decided that to really
ameliorate
it's a small minority of of kids who
produce all the aggressive acts predo
distribution same thing they're almost
so it's quite cool actually
if you're a scientist i suppose if you
look at two-year-olds you put them in a
room
a small proportion of the two-year-olds
will kick bite hit and steal
it's only five percent and almost all of
them are male
now if you track those kids over the
next two years most of them get
socialized out of that
those that don't tend to stay
anti-social and develop criminal
behavior later
so it's it's socializable it can be it
can be rectified between two and four
the problem was is that
if that's the case imagine a government
enterprise set up to ameliorate that
gets pretty damn invasive when the
government has to start figuring out how
you're going to raise your two-year-old
right
so and
this cognitive ability problem might be
something that's quite similar like one
of the things that's interesting about
kids that become
literate versus kids that don't
is that the kids that become literate
are exposed to so many more books and
words that you can hardly believe it
it's another pareto distribution and i
see you know
my kids they were dragging books around
when they were 12 months old before they
well before they could read but they
were familiarizing themselves with the
objects and you know and becoming
friends with them in a kind of
non-verbal way and we don't know the we
don't know the pathway to that kind of
that kind of literacy or the nature of
the relationship between that and the
development of cognitive ability
well this is a much more hopeful
uh vision isn't it a one in which there
are
perhaps not yet fully determined uh
interventions that can ameliorate or
compensate that's like the glasses that
i'm wearing that allow me to see despite
my
genetic
disability
i i thought the spirit of
of charles murray and richard hernstein
in 1994 when the bell curve was
published was that
sorry but the best that we could
determine
these interventions early childhood
education or whatever that might be
don't seem to be able to have
much of an effort so i studied that for
about 20 years looking at exactly that
and so
the head start programs
they
what happened to kids who went through
head start the hope was that if you got
kids early enough you could give them a
head start cognitively and that that
would spiral upward you know in one of
these positive loops
but that didn't happen what happened was
the kids who went to head start leapt
ahead of their peers
cognitively but the peers caught up by
grade six and all the differences
disappeared except the head start kids
were less likely to drop out of school
to become criminal and to become
pregnant you know young
so it wasn't nothing but it didn't work
cognitively
but
i looked into head start in more detail
you know
it was also a make work program so the
people who were the head start teachers
weren't necessarily particularly trained
it's really hard when you're dealing
with say three-year-olds
to get one-on-one time with them
and teach them something like basic
literacy because there's so many if you
have five three-year-olds it's like
you're spending 90 percent of your time
making sure that they're alive you know
dressing them and so forth so the amount
of time in head start that was actually
devoted to cognitive training was
minimal
and so we don't know actually we don't
know yet i don't think
now what about the ability to enhance
other uh traits not in cognitive
ability but i don't know perseverance or
uh you know uh
resilience or uh well
well
resilience and compensate compensate for
the fact that they're not going to get
any smarter at the cognitive thing but
they might actually get to be much uh
more effective people by enhancing these
other dimensions of their of their
performance well the fact that the head
start kids didn't get
didn't drop out of school probably
reflected at least to some degree the
fact that they behaved better so they
were more socialized and the theory was
that some of those kids were removed
from pretty terrible environments and
protected a bit by the fact that they
were going to head start they got
socialized earlier so they're able to
interact in groups better they weren't
as disruptive in classrooms so at the
same level of cognitive ability they
were still more likely to get through
school
and that wasn't nothing and so yes some
of those things are perhaps more
ameliorable still not a simple thing
because a lot of you know if that window
for the socialization of aggressive
behavior among aggressive boys is
between two and four years of age
then that's that's that's a tough place
for governments to
or society as such to intervene gets you
know because it gets invasive that's
that's and that's a big problem
because you don't also don't want to
encourage government overreach
so okay let me ask you some more
questions here
i
you're yeah one of the things i really
got curious about when i was reading
about you
you claimed in a speech to oxford not a
claim you said you know that your
political views had really shifted a lot
in your life from left to center to
right and then back
i think farther left than you were when
you started is that is that an accurate
description
yeah and then back right again and i
don't know if i'm farther right when i
was when i was right before i was left
yeah that i have i have vacillated a
little bit over the years and so what
what's what's driven that and what do
you make of that because i've noticed as
my political opinions have changed that
i was just as convinced that i was right
when i thought the opposite thing as i
am now and so you know
that sort of says more about me than the
beliefs i suppose but what do you make
of that shift um
well i think it's this is personal to me
i think the story that i'm i'm telling
uh in in the uh memoir that i'm working
on now is is uh that
i needed to
let me let me start at the beginning so
i come up as a working-class kid in
chicago and i'm black and it's the 1960s
1970s i'm sort of naturally
a liberal democrat by disposition or by
you know osmosis by the atmosphere
everybody was
i get to graduate school and get a
training in economics
and i get a green eye shade on and i
start like wanting to do my sums you
know i started like recognizing there's
no free lunch you know that that there
are incentives that you know there's
unintended consequences that there's
cause and effect there's not a program
for everything that i we have to worry
about inflation that yet etc so i become
more
of a neo-liberal what they would call
today in the era i become more of a
free-market economist i become more
conservative
and ronald reagan comes along in the
early 1980s and i'm one of the few black
people
on the planet who thought that
he had it right more than he had it
wrong about a lot of these questions
at the same time i am observing what's
going on in inner city america in the
big cities across the country i grew up
in chicago but i taught at the
university of michigan i happen to know
a little bit about detroit i can read
the newspaper i can see what's going on
in you know baltimore st louis or
cleveland or pittsburgh or new york or
los angeles whatever the inner city the
ghettos
the violence the schools that don't work
the out of wedlock burst the low
employment numbers the uh culture that's
coarse and that's that's
leading to a lot of dysfunction and a
lot of problems
and i'm looking at the rhetoric of the
democratic party or of the civil rights
leadership which seems to me to be kind
of
completely
out of touch with reality this is the
early 1980s and i find myself moving
further and further to the right and i
end up
a reagan republican
um this is going to be short the short
version
i go through some profound life-changing
traumatic experiences
i have a big public fall i was up for a
government job i had to withdraw amid
sexual scandal
i have a drug addiction problem i get
caught by the police in possession of
illicit substances i need to go into
rehab i spend
months at a psychiatric hospital in
belmont massachusetts trying to learn
how to not use cocaine
i come out of that
through a religious conversion i mean
the plot thickens
i'm a born-again christian now i'm a
recovering cocaine addict i'm a you know
uh a bad boy black conservative who's
given the uh you know his comeuppance
with his public humiliation and i begin
to rethink my politics moving in the
left direction in part i think under the
pressure of just wanting to
be able to go home again just wanting to
find a place where i could be
comfortable within my own skin
uh in part perhaps because i had some
misgivings about some of the
uh you know dimensions of the
conservative uh political frame that uh
rita was writing off people at the
bottom and not thinking hard enough as
you and i have been trying to think in
this conversation about what could
really be done so i find myself moving
back to the left again but then we get
to like 2009 2010 2011 2012 2013-14 uh
things like the uh
michael brown thing in uh
ferguson missouri and
uh the trayvon martin thing in sanford
florida and the eric garner thing in
staten island new york and the tamir
rice thing in cleveland ohio and all of
that and the black lives matter movement
comes up and the woke
anti-racism movement
comes up and
now i find myself it's like deja vu all
over again i find myself thrown back to
the 1980s and the instinct within me is
to resist
resist resist the
political correctness
yeah so some of the so some of that is
is you moving in your life but some of
that is the political landscape also
shifting around you which
issues the political landscape shifts
hard to the left and i find myself again
i find myself lamenting some of the
earlier changes when i said you know my
feelings about affirmative action which
i was instinctively against before i was
for it
before i was against it my feelings
maybe they were right all along in the
first place maybe i should not have
broken my friendship with justice
clarence thomas over the california
uh civil rights initiative of uh 1996
which banned affirmative action in the
state the justice and i who were friends
decided that we were not going to talk
again because i could not
support the anti-affirmative action move
at that time ten years earlier i would
have supported it today i would support
it yeah well it's a tough question that
and that's a really tough question so
it's no wonder you know that a
thoughtful person might fascillate on
that because there are profound things
to be said on both sides of that
argument hey can i ask you and you don't
have to answer this
i guess it's the clinician in me
so i studied alcoholism and drug abuse
and addiction
as my primary research topic when i was
grad student and one of the things that
was well known among alcoholism
researchers at that time and hard-edged
researchers was that
religious transformation was about the
only reliable treatment so to speak for
alcoholism no alcoholism treatment
programs work and that's still the truth
today no matter what people say they
just don't work that doesn't mean people
don't stop because they do
but
spiritual transformation seems to be a
ticket out of drug addiction and
it's interesting in that regard for
example that roland griffiths and his
team investigating psychedelic mushroom
psilocybin have shown that one dose
producing a mystical experience produces
75 percent
permanent cessation in smokers
most powerful pharmacological
intervention it's unbelievable and
that's not there he's done all sorts of
other interesting and he's a hard-edged
research scientist this guy's no like
pie in the sky mystic it's really
something
there's really something to this that we
don't understand and could i ask you you
said you were struggling with addiction
problems that's a catastrophe and you
had this
religious transformation
what what was that exactly and why do
you think it was relevant to the drug
abuse issue well why did it help you
stop
okay i'm not sure i know the answer to
the question but i understand the
question and um
there were really two dimensions to my
spiritual experience in the late 1980s
when i was a cocaine addict and it was
killing me it was killing me
one of them was explicitly religious i
was born again i became a
born-again christian i was baptized at
the age of 40 i believed came to believe
that our lord and savior jesus christ as
we would have put it
died for me personally glenn lowry and
that there was a path
to my having a relationship with
almighty god
through my belief in jesus christ now
i'm not trying to proselytize here i
actually don't have the same degree of
religious forever contemporary in my
life now as i did at that time but i
came to believe that the other thing
that was of a spiritual significance for
me was the alcoholics anonymous program
you know the 12 steps you know
i admitted that i was an alcoholic in my
life had become unmanageable i came to
believe that the power greater than
myself really restored me to sadly i
made a decision to turn my will and my
life over to the care of god as i
understood him
and one day at a time i was going to not
drink i was going to talk to my sponsor
i was going to go to my meetings i was
going to deal with whatever came up in
life without drinking because i know
that i'm an alcoholic and my life had
become unmanageable and etc right right
yeah well that's when the program has a
strong spiritual slash religious
underpinning and that's part of the
influence of carl jung who was
instrumental as a thinker yes yes the
person who set up a a
was in correspondence with young quite
intensely and so it's it's influenced a
lot by his
thoughts about the psychology of
religion and
i just want to respond to your question
yes was what did the spirituality do for
me and it took me out of myself it made
me humble it and it made me patient and
it made me wanting to stifle stifle
myself and to just
um you know
let go and let god that was another one
of the bumper stickers
right that we used to have that i was my
own worst enemy that i needed to
surrender that i that it was a kind of
radical humility
uh in it yeah well you need that radical
humility if you're dealing with an
addiction problem there's no doubt about
that because that's that's a wicked
devil to have in your head and
if there's any arrogance and pride in
you that's going to be a real obstacle
to any to any healthful recovery that's
for sure
yeah i'll tell you a story if you've got
time i'm in the halfway house and it's
run by this grizzled old irishman
uh bob brown is his name and he's been
getting men sober for a quarter century
and i'm in this halfway house with
drunks who've been sleeping in boxes in
the subway station and people just come
out of prison and
you know just get out of the detox and
whatnot and i'm the only professor in
the halfway house okay
so one day uh the bob brown is listening
to me interact with a counselor and i'm
i'm
snowing the consulate with how much i
know about the 12-step program because i
know because i'm a professor and i have
read the book and i know it all okay
and bob rowley turns to me the director
he overrides the consular and he says
you know what professor lowry
if you're so smart answer me this
what were you doing out there in the
streets of boston showing your ass just
like a n-word
from the projects
he didn't say n-word
this is a white guy he's an irishman
he he confronted me with this uh slur
and this insult
i'm professor at harvard university and
this guy is talking to me like i was you
know an n word
from the project
and my first instinct this is just the
point about stifling yourself and about
radical humility my first impulse
was to strike him but then i looked and
he stood six three and he weighed 280
pounds so i decided against that
that seems wise
my next alternative was the boat from
the house i didn't need to be there
there was no law keeping me there to
hell with him i'm not going to allow
anybody to talk to me like that
but my christian
teaching
allowed me to see
that i did not know the answer to the
question
[Music]
the question was what was i doing
out there doing what i was doing i had
no idea what i was doing yeah well and a
more specific question right it's like
clearly you're smart and so how do you
reconcile the gap there and that's like
that's a big question and intelligence
is not wisdom that's for sure
okay and so i decided that i had better
stay put
right where i was in that halfway house
i took it i took the insult without
comment i stayed there for another five
months and i haven't used cocaine since
how was 1989
how did you have the confidence to
regain your position and to re-adopt it
after having gone through that that
category i had the loving support of my
wife linda lowry who is no longer living
she died 11 years ago
i had the
very strong support of harvard
university and of my colleagues and
friends there
who
continued to afford me the opportunity
to show that i was worth a damn and that
i could get it back together again i
ultimately left
and moved across the street to boston
university a very fine place and i had a
good job there and i left and way
because
they were so nice to me at harvard i
couldn't bear it
i mean i i i felt like i didn't
deserve
their uh forgiveness at some level i
wanted to strike out and start again
someplace on my own i didn't want to let
them be as nice to me as they were being
uh
but uh
i had support is is is one thing that
i'm having the other thing is uh i got
back to science i had been drifting into
a political i was a big public
intellectual in the 1980s i was writing
in commentary magazine and then the new
republic magazine when it was a place
worth writing in
and and other such venues and you know i
had friends in the reagan administration
i was friends with people like
would be soon to be justice thomas and
many others i was a high-flying
conservative black intellectual
um
and and
uh
you know i i yeah actually i forgot i
forgot what i was saying you were you
were saying you got back to the science
oh that's it exactly exactly i said
to hell with all this newspaper stuff
to uh all these arguments with all these
people
let me just try to remind myself what i
what i fell in love with when i became
an economist in the first place i had
four
papers in the american economic review
in 1993.
you know
i mean
all right so that's basically the
equivalent for those who are listening
that's kind of like the equivalent of
doing a whole phd in one year i would
say because you can get a phd with three
papers if they're well crafted so that's
about what that is and i was publishing
up a storm between 93 and 96 97 i
published you know six or seven really
strong papers that got thousands of
citations and stuff like that even to
this day these papers are cited so i
went back to doing economics and that i
think allowed me to get my feet under
myself and get grounded again and i
eventually have come back to doing
public intellectual work obviously but
um
in those years i why have you come back
and like you have a youtube channel and
maybe we can close the discussion with
this is kind of where i wanted to close
is
you are a public figure again you have a
youtube channel and a podcast you're
trying to
you're you're trying to speak
directly to the to the public again and
why why are you driven to do that and
and how is it going it's going okay i
think uh the glenn lowry show it's the
youtube channel and
glennlowery.substack is the newsletter
and yeah we're putting out content every
week and we've got you know some
followers and whatnot i
you know i'm i'm
able to see that if uh brown university
were to somehow find a way of getting me
off the payroll i might still be able to
make a living out here in the
in the world because there are people
who are following and who want to
support
so that's all good and it's gratifying
i'm on a mission uh
jordan and i'm glad you asked
uh i do collaborate with john mcwhorter
he's a fine guy he writes for the new
york times he teaches at columbia
university and twice a month he and i
hold forth
the other two weeks a month i will have
other guests
we call ourselves the woke busters now
some people object they say oh that
doesn't rhyme with ghostbuster
but but it captures the idea the idea is
the world has gone mad
uh the race questions on diversity
equity and inclusion on
systemic racism on cultural
appropriations on microaggressions on
whatever the world has gone mad
completely mad
the universities are in danger this is
me i don't want to speak for john
mcwhorter but i don't think he disagrees
with this uh because the
barbarians are at the gates no they've
overrun the gates and they approach the
citadel they they are a threat to the
great tradition i got some good news for
you then yeah yeah help me out well you
know i got disinvited to cambridge
university
two years ago two and a half years ago i
was going to go there and study with
some of their experts on exodus because
i wanted to do a public lecture series
on exodus
and
i
a picture of me surfaced with this guy i
had like 15 000 photos of me taken with
people that year by the way anyways he
wore a t-shirt that had
criticisms of islam on it and that
surfaced and
they disinvited me and i found out about
it on twitter which wasn't the best way
to find out about it in any case
people have been working behind the
scenes since then to modify the free
speech policies at cambridge to make it
impossible to disinvite someone unless
they're doing something illegal
and that passed with a full vote of the
faculty
85 percent of them voted in favor of it
and it looks like there is going to be
similar adjustments made to uk law
oh that's fantastic was it oz guinness
that you were going to work with no it
was uh james orr and nigel baker
primarily
oh i see i just saw a book of oz
guinness called the magna carta of
humanity which argues about the book of
exodus that it's a foundational oh oh i
should know that then i should i should
write that down what's it called it's
called the magna carter
of humanity and the author is oz
guinness
oz guinness okay i will look that up
yeah well it's a it's a fundamental
transformation narrative exodus and it
was i wouldn't have been able to go
anyways because i was too ill and so was
my wife but that's beside the point but
you know that this is a very positive
thing this development and
hopefully well hopefully it will become
uk law that is the plan
whether the legislation will pass and
that will also set up an ombudsman as i
understand
outside the university system so if a
professor gets nailed by the politically
correct types or
or right-wing conservatives for that
matter it won't matter
and
he'll he or she will have recourse to
this ombudsman to see if the fundamental
right to free speech at uk universities
has been violated and so it'll
well so that's all part of it and so
this is good news and
well you're a trailblazer in that regard
and may uh may whatever has struck in
cambridge uh catch over here uh i just
heard about this guy from chicago
uh the planetary scientist who was given
a lecture at to give this big name
lecture at mit
uh who was cancelled because he had
spoken out in a magazine about
affirmative action which he says you
know let's not do that by race let's you
know do it on the basis of individual
qualification this is a defensible
position it seems to me but uh certainly
not something a person should be
counseled for but so sensitive are the
guardians of
a virtue at these places that they
they're able to get away with that kind
of thing now yeah yeah well it's become
bureaucratized to a large degree too and
you know part of that's the faculty's
fault too because my observation of
universities is that faculty the faculty
is a has allowed administrative creep
for about three decades without doing
anything about it because it was easier
not to and so
you know i think as a faculty member i
regard all of us to blame for precisely
this this tremendous growth in
administration and the
the evolution of these
dei
uh uh empires especially in hr
yeah well you asked me you know um
uh what i was uh why i was being a
public intellectual again and what i
hope to accomplish and and i just wanted
to
add
that after george floyd was killed by
derek shoving the police officer in
minneapolis
and there were
protests that broke out in cities around
the world and especially cities around
the united states and some of those
protests turned violent
and there was riotous behavior and
assaults on police officers and there
was arson and looting
and there was there was general disorder
and it's a big political football and
people are on all sides of it and
they're defenders of it and so forth and
so on
but it occurred to me
that i did not even know
that the incident that happened with a
white police officer and the black
gentleman who died who was killed was a
racial incident i i say i did not know
that it was a racial incident all i knew
was that the police officer was white
and that the man who was killed was
black
it didn't follow from that
that it was a racial incident we were
making it into a racial instead we being
all of us here in the united states we
were making it into
a reenactment of old american dramas of
lynching and the murder of black people
by rogue police and
so forth and so on
we
took that thing
and we said yes see here we have proof
of the knee on the neck of black america
that's what
al sharpton the activist said at the
funeral of joyful he said america has
its knee on our neck and i thought
this great country of 330 million people
with 40 million black people
and here we are
150 years after slavery in a half
century since martin luther king was
killed
really
that's going to be the narrative for our
country's politics for the next decade
for the next 15 years this is what we're
going to teach to our children this is
how we're going to arrange our
media coverage of these events this is
that's a disaster for this country okay
so how how can you say that when you
also have spoken so eloquently on topics
such as the differential incarceration
rate this is not an assault on your
statement by the way i'm very curious
because
obviously you know you've spoken
profoundly about the danger of that
differential incarceration rate and you
can see that it's not that easy to
conceptually disentangle especially if
you're politically motivated but even if
you're not the an event like that from
that broader narrative that something
you know something's not right
structurally and perhaps this is a
reflection of it
but well so i i don't know how to
reconcile those two viewpoints i don't
know how you reconcile them
with difficulty i suppose i could say
because they do point in slightly
different maybe even more than slightly
different directions but i'm trying to
keep my perspective
right i i do think that the uh advent of
what they call mass incarceration two
and a quarter million people under lock
and key on a given day half of them are
45 of them being black people when we're
12 of the population
uh as a way of doing business going
forward without any
uh sense of
urgency of reform without any revisiting
of you know our drug laws or our
sentencing or whatever without any uh
attention to what is supposed to happen
when someone is in prison rehabilitation
and whatnot without any exploration of
alternatives to incarceration as ways of
responding to criminal offending is bad
for our country i do believe that and i
believe the racial aspect of that echoes
with our history in ways that are
uh that are uh dangerous and that we
dare not neglect i i'm the same guy
on on the other hand i think
if you racialized the discussion of
crime and punishment um there was the
woman who was murdered at columbia
university a few years ago and her
she was killed by these kids who were
just trying to rob her and they ended up
stabbing her to death she was white she
was a you know
i'm sorry i don't remember her name
offhand
uh but you know she was a lovely young
woman and innocent is how she's going to
appear in the photograph and she
certainly did nothing to deserve what
befell her and she was white
the great
the other side of it yeah right tessa
tessa something is her last name i can't
recall the kids who killed her were
black kids from around harlem
they were in the park yeah they were
looking for a quick score they had a
knife the woman is lying she bleeds out
now they've convicted one of them has
been convicted and i'm looking at the
photo in the newspaper and here's this
black kid he looks like a black kid
who's
16 18 years old he's a kid he's from
this impoverished neighborhood he's
black
and the woman is white
i don't want that incident processed in
terms of black kid murders white women
yeah okay so maybe it's an issue maybe
it's an issue of conflation careless
conflation of levels of analysis say
because
you you you're talking about
a high resolution analysis of structural
problems in the in the penal system
and
to to put that george floyd event to
cram that into the same narrative it
sort of be speaks of undifferentiated
thought and so and then you point out
that the danger of that is well if
you're going to racialize the white cop
against the black the
black victim of of the of of the of the
homicide well then why can't the same
thing be done exactly the same way when
the reverse happens and maybe we
shouldn't do any or we should do as
little of that as we possibly can that
doesn't mean we shouldn't take a look at
these bigger structural issues but we
shouldn't cram it all together in one
thing because it's not
that's very well put jordan that's
exactly what i'm trying to say you said
it better than i did
well i listened to you so that was a big
help by the way if we do cram it all
into one thing god help us because there
are people uh and and they're not gonna
speak out there are people uh who will
see it process it just as i hope they
would not do black thug murders innocent
white girl and and and harbor a
resentment and nurse that resentment and
that's a tinder box that's a powder keg
waiting to be lit and we can dismiss it
if we want to but those people are not
entirely wrong
in their sentiment they they need to be
disabused of that instinct that that
that instinct to conflate those levels
of analysis yeah yeah yeah well that's
part of the problem i have with ideology
is that that's
ideology is so low resolution it it does
that conflation it doesn't notice
and when you get educated you start
differentiating it's like and that's
kind of what you said happened to you
when you became more conservative once
you got more educated it's like oh this
is when i take this apart and see all
the moving paces this is way more
complex than my low resolution
representation guided me to believe to
begin with
and that's that i mean i've experienced
that many times in my life when i tried
to take problems apart so they could be
solved instead of just discussed let's
say you have to make a high resolution
model before you can get anywhere that's
true in clinical practice and i think
it's true in public policy and partly
what we're doing when we're educating
people if we're doing it right is saying
hey you know you've got a map of the
world but it's it's not very detailed
and when you really look at it
well you know here's the complexity
and that's what we're actually
contending with people don't like that
because well it's complex right
and you have the simple solution at hand
to begin with but the problem is it
isn't
the right tool for the job
you got to make it high resolution now
it takes a lot of work
so thank you very much for talking to me
today it was a real pleasure discussing
things with you and i probably talk too
much because i usually do but
i apologize for that but i enjoyed it
very much nice to meet you jordan thank
you it was a pleasure meeting you and
and good luck with your endeavors in the
future hopefully we'll meet some point
and hopefully we'll get a chance to talk
again and say hi to dr mcquarter for me
i will do that
all right
all right
[Music]
you